we begin with david at the white house
david
hi neil good morning to you a lot of
news this morning at the white house the
president tweeting several times
about alleged fraud and i say alleged
fraud because there's absolutely no
proof right now that there is any fraud
with some of this ballot counting but he
tweeted that this morning
our sources also say president trump has
no intentions to concede this race
at this time and he plans to continue
this through the courts as long as
possible
i want to put up a full screen right now
it's a screen grab i took just a few
minutes ago you can see
four of the president's tweets this
morning blocked by twitter they're
flagged
as potential misinformation in the
tweets he's talking about ballot
counting and alluding to fraud
just a few months ago it was big news
when twitter flagged its first
presidential tweet but neil over the
past week it's happened
frequently this morning votes will
continue
to be counted in philadelphia where the
president is alleging some of that fraud
and corruption
but his team has yet to show a specific
instance of that fraud as i mentioned
republicans and democrats have been
allowed inside
to watch vote counting specifically in
pennsylvania and in other states and
neil last night supreme court justice
samuel alito
ordered ballots received after 8 pm on
election day in pennsylvania
be segregated that means locking them
down for the time being
it's likely they'll be counted but this
keeps those late ones separate
the normally trump friendly wall street
journal editorial page out with a new
op-ed last night i want to read part of
it it says
mr trump hates to lose and no doubt he
will fight to the end
but if defeat comes he will serve
himself and his country best
by honoring america's democratic
traditions and leaving
office with dignity also breaking
overnight specifically from the white
house we have confirmed
that white house chief of staff mark
meadows tested positive for kova 19.
we have video of him on monday in
scranton the day before the election he
was seen without a mask
in some instances he was high-fiving
supporters not adhering to any
social distancing guidelines put forward
by the cdc
he was in with the president at campaign
headquarters the next day on election
day
in the east room overnight about 2 30 in
the morning both times
he was not wearing a mask we're told
that he is in frequent contact though
neil
with members of the administration
including the president he said to be
doing fine
and of course we wish him well neil all
right david thank you very much